Leena is with us in New York hi Lina
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi can I
get your advice on something
sure we're going to help my husband was
offered an opportunity he worked for a
national shipping company and he was
often an opportunity to relocate to a
specific site in North Carolina this
position has not came up in the five
years that we've been looking and it was
just came available and we are on baby
step two we have 12,000 and 400 left on
our car which we have listed we make
$85,000 a year we owe 80,000 on our home
the CMA came back at 210 and I don't
know if it's a good decision to take
this once-in-a-lifetime with no
emergency fun and not being out of that
out of number two so you would move to
North Carolina to take the job yeah and
he would get how much of an income
increase his income would remain the
same and I could possibly get an income
increase myself I'm part time now and
why are you moving to get a break-even
on income he's moving because he hates
the cold okay are you from North
Carolina originally yes okay but our
family is actually all over the place
and majority of our fam they're all over
the place so we can't even say family
move okay way or the other you know what
I mean but he would just he would rather
live in North Carolina than in New York
correct
that's simple okay he hates the cold and
he said that affects us health okay and
how and what do you make a year
I make thirty four thousand part-time
but I'm finishing up a leadership health
care degree so but where I live is so
rural like the closest hospital where I
work as an hour away from me now or
no sir on now in North Carolina it would
put me into a full time I already spoke
to the manager down there they're hiring
two full-time positions okay so your
your income would increase yes yes sad
you would be living where you all want
to live do you want to live in North
Carolina
yes okay so I think you sell your house
and you move to North Carolina even
though we have no emergency fund you
know you have a hundred thousand dollars
in equity right as you sell your house
you'll be dead for you have an emergency
fund use the rest of it as a down
payment when you move in North Carolina
okay so just go there and rent and just
put our house here on the market yep and
hope it sells and they don't pay any of
the moving costs or anything now you
sure yeah it's as he asked I can have a
mask because it's an hour away from the
beach it's like the ideal spot that
position never doesn't matter most
companies that move people pay something
to move them I think their policy is
only if they only if it's like a only if
they can't fill it like if it was
Arkansas or something not coastal North
Carolina okay all right well I I think I
push on that and see if I get some help
moving but yeah I'm making this move get
you how quick will your house sell it
the realtor said because it's a ranch
house there's nothing like that we left
enough so early that cm the gas
companies have pulled out so the market
around here is horrible but our style of
house is the ranch and where a lot of
elderly retire into this area that our
house probably would sell quickly good
get it on the market aggressively priced
not giving it away but a good price
cheap price get it sold fast okay and
get yourself out of there I don't see
any reason to stay there I didn't hear
any I didn't hear you begging me in any
way to stay there I'm just worried about
them not having the emergency fund well
you're going to get the money out your
house and you're going to be fine
and you guys got to make you know you
need to stop until you make the move
stop your debt snowball and pile up some
- to make the move if they're not going
to give you any help moving and you need
to go in and ask for some help moving so
I'll take it but you need to give me
some moving and just see what they say
they'll probably do it be surprised what
they do if you just ask so I'm and don't
go in there and just like oh please no
no really I mean hey I'm ready to take
it can you give me some help moving if
you can do that I'm ready to go and just
see what they say they'll they'll
probably give you a little help you
never know you never know so obviously
they think the world of him and they
would like to see him there rather than
where he is and so it's probably worth
something to them to do that good
question thank you for joining us hey
you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you are
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right
kind of better than the dayroom 2
channel I'll tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you